what's going on guys welcome to another
stock indicators in mathematics tutorial
within Python where we left off we were
actually calculating Bollinger Bands now
let's actually graph them up so if you
don't have the starter file the starter
file for that creates basically this
chart right here as an example I do have
all the code for that right here and so
we're just gonna be inputting that code
in there so if you don't have the code
just literally highlight it all copy and
paste it into an empty script come over
here and somewhere I've got an entry
script yeah paste and then we're gonna
take this one and this Bollinger Bands
tutorial is gonna be different than most
of the indicator tutorials so mostly
indicators right the indicators
themselves
are gonna go and as we've done so far
for the most part the indicators have
gone down in this like bottom section
here that I've just left blank Bollinger
Bands on the other hand they actually go
up here okay so this time we're gonna be
graphing Bollinger Bands on top of here
and I am just gonna leave the simple
moving averages there for this video but
you can take them out and if you do take
them out just understand that you have
to get rid of the legend because if you
take them out of the legend is going to
try and plot stuff up that doesn't exist
and it's gonna get very angry with you
so just a forewarning
so anyway move this over now so to put
them up let's see this was where then
there's okay so this is the graphing
thing so basically those the simple
moving averages are graphed well here's
the candlestick and they're plotted up
right here just if you wanted to just
make them go away you can just give them
an alpha of zero but it would still be
there in the legend anyway so what we
want to do is this was the original here
and what we want to do is we already
have moving average in there don't have
standard deviation to find and we don't
have Bollinger Bands defined so what we
want to do is go ahead and just copy all
of this won't even go all the way down
to this copy that and go into here and
actually what I'm gonna go ahead and do
is make the font smaller so we
see this operation better
so under graph data where we define a x
1.is here so I'm just gonna guess I'll
make some space under here so you have
plenty of space so right underneath that
candlestick ax 1 just tab over a little
bit hit paste and we're gonna pry need
to indent this stuff twice I think is
usually what we have to do so yeah so
two indents and you should be all set
now the next thing we want to do is
actually chart the stuff up we did call
it with DT BBB and B so now all we have
to do really to plot it is call it out
and encase it in a try and accept loop
just encase try except exception e print
string E and in fact let me zoom us back
in okay so now all we want to do is ax 1
because that's the axis from the plot on
what do we want to plot what we want
applied d TB and then we can choose any
color so you can just copy this color
you can pick another color if you want
but the one that I use was c1 f9 f7 and
then we're gonna give it a slight alpha
equals 0.7 no I'm gonna go ahead and
just copy this and actually let's go
ahead and add in the other thing we want
to do is minus SP for starting point if
if you want to know more about that you
have to watch the tutorial video or
series for actual charting stocks in
Python now paste paste and now that
we've got all that covered so we've got
TB we want to do
EB oops make sure that TVB b and then
we'll plot the middle line there and
that should be it so now we should be
able to run this hopefully no errors
we'll find out very soon and
yep so now we pick the stock that we
want to plot will do eBay and what you
should get hopefully is this now
obviously it looks pretty messy because
we have these other moving averages here
and that's bothering me enough that I
think I'll show you guys how to get rid
of them real quick it's so anyway so
we're confident at work now let me just
show you how to get rid of those simple
moving averages if you want to otherwise
the video is over and you can go do
something else if you want so the first
thing we will really want to do is we
want to silence the plotting of those
simple moving air I guess it was below
this so they're being plotted here and
here now the other thing we have is the
legend and the legend is gonna ask for
this stuff so we need to silence the
legend so I'm just gonna do a find for
legend and this is this entire text here
is for the legend so we're gonna comment
it out and I think that would be enough
to get that to leave us alone now so
let's try it we won't get any errors you
boo yeah okay so we got rid of all that
junk and so now you can just see the
graph itself obviously without anything
down here but you could just if you want
leave the Bollinger Bands on there as we
go through other ones but there will be
other indicators that are will be like
on the chart itself on the prices anyway
so that's gonna conclude the Bollinger
Bands tutorial series hopefully you guys
enjoyed as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and it's he'll next time